folks we did it
we did it uh i will not lie
folks that that was a wilder ride that
was a wild ride and you guys almost got
me you almost got me
100 subscribers oh
man let me tell you a story about two
months ago my old buddy told me that
he bet i couldn't fool a hundred people
into thinking that i was literate that i
knew how to read
and we made a bet in this bet he said if
you can
get 100 subscribers pretending like you
know how to read
books i will give you a hundred bucks
and guess what folks
last week i made 100 bucks and that's
because of you that's because
of you you beautiful silly fools i mean
i mean come on the signs were all there
hold on let me open this
this gin folks how did you not see it
mission accomplished right i mean i can
shut this whole thing down i don't know
how to read i'm actually a minecraft
streamer i stream on twitch you can
catch me man carrying thing on twitch i
i stream minecraft that's all i [ __ ]
do
you know i never went to high school i
never went to middle school and i never
even went to elementary school i do not
know how to read
in all serious note yes though
in all seriousness 100 subscribers
already like that's cool
that's cool i'm still a little bit
surprised that people
just you just want to watch me talk
about about books
and just sit in this chair in this
warehouse in pasadena i really enjoy it
yeah this has been a really fun journey
you know i've met some
some wonderful booktubers and overall i
have to say the booktube community is
incredibly warm
and friendly and i'm excited to keep
watching
people's videos and commenting and
exploring books and talking about books
because let me tell you this quarantine
life
there's not a lot of people to talk
books with i'm really happy to to be
part of this little niche on the
internet where we can
share our our our [ __ ] opinions right
here's to
the end of the channel we had a good run
i can finally give it up because i
i hit my goal no not not really i'm
gonna keep making videos
by the way i am not a twitch streamer i
do not stream minecraft but when i hit
if i ever hit 10
000 subscribers this becomes a minecraft
let's play channel like i'm just warning
myself i'm warning you people who are
subscribed to this channel that once i
hit
10 000 subscribers no more books no more
it's just minecraft you're gonna be have
to watch videos that are titled like
epic day
on skyblock minecraft or or
you know minecraft hunter versus
speedrunner
swordsman like you're you're just gonna
have to deal with that but
this is way down the road i mean this is
100 subscribers we're talking about 10
000 subscribers i'm just giving people a
heads up
don't act like you're surprised i think
that's all i have to say i don't know
what do people usually do for videos
for the 100 what would be special what
would you guys like to see i can
you know what i'm gonna show you the top
shelf i'm gonna do it
wow
that was worth it wasn't it it's very
late
thanks for watching and let's let's keep
talking about books all right
all right